we're talking with the star of one of my
favorite shows ghosts the actor Danielle
Pinnock plays the ghost of a Prohibition
era singer jazz singer to be exact named
Alberta and she lives in the Woodstone
mansion with the other ghosts they
include a viking a Native American and a
Victorian era woman named Hedy and many
more after much speculation we finally
learned last week who killed Alberta
spoiler alert partial at least it turns
out that Hedy knew the killer all along
in tonight's season two finale Alberta
confronts Hedy for keeping this massive
secret take a look
information for a hundred years hedy's
been pretending to be my friend
withholding the truth about how I died
this was a century of betrayal and I
hope this court remembers that when it
comes time to sentence up
Hedy do you deny these charges
I do not
but I ask that the court considered the
following
the heady of a hundred years ago stayed
silent
for many reasons but the heady that
stands before you today did not
Danielle Pinnock joins us now looking
like a flower
the best way to celebrate my birthday I
am so happy birthday happy birthday what
birthday is it do you want to say oh
yeah 35.
um and I'm just really grateful because
I've always wanted to be on this show
and Miss Dale I just got to tell you
there's a consolation of black women who
have inspired me in my artistic Journey
you're one of them oh thank you thank
you that's beautiful thank you well look
I'm grateful that the show ghosts is in
the world
I watched a whole bunch of them on the
train yesterday uh dressed up as one of
the characters oh yeah
that's so great and so it's been a
thrill in this job to be able to meet so
many of you guys uh and now you Alberta
is a great character one of the things
that happens on the show so people
understand is that the ghosts they died
long ago and now they're all kind of
friends and they take turns kind of
investigating what happened to them in
their life and your your death was a
mystery oh yeah
um Mariska Hard To Say watch out okay
Alberta is a 1920s prohibition Ergo
she's a jazz singer she's a diva to the
fullest degree
um and I like to say that she is a hot
mess with a heart of gold and that's
exactly what her murder mystery was it
was a hot mess I had to do a podcast oh
yeah which is great so when you found
out who did it were you shopping don't
give anything away oh yes it's already
aired I know but I'll keep people that
want to watch and find out I'll I'll
hold a little bit here oh yeah I gasped
you did out loud in the table room
people were like Daniel why are you
screaming like this I was like I've been
waiting for
differently now
um but yeah I was fully surprised and I
just loved how everything played out uh
last week when we find out it's just
been an honor playing this character to
breathe life into Alberta's afterlife
um as a black woman that time period in
the Harlem Renaissance was so important
to our culture and so to be able to
perform and play this character it's
just been a dream come true let's talk
about you though because it says that
you were ready to quit acting before you
got this role sure was you're ready to
give up how come you know I think after
20 years of hearing no and not getting
that big yes it wears on you you know
and I got very depressed and I remember
I auditioned for this big screen test
role and it didn't happen and so to be
honest I was in bed for three months I
was like you know what I'm not doing
this anymore I just need to take a break
and I know the saying is you know just
keep hustling keep going but I think
sometimes you just need to pause so I'm
so glad that I took my pause I took my
break I reassessed I said you know what
I love this too much to say no forever
so let me just get back on the horse and
do it and I'm so glad because Ghost came
and it's the biggest blessing of my life
can we talk about your journey though
because you were not originally cast in
this role from one first generation
American to another take me yeah
tell me about your journey yes um well
my family is Jamaican I'm first
generation Jamaican American all right
um my mom is oh there you are yeah oh my
God look at Mom and Dad she's an
incredible incredible human
um and the thing the common thing with
immigrants is that you hear that we're
supposed to be lawyers and doctors and
yeah that's right that one and she
really just allowed me to live my dreams
out loud she paid for my piano lessons
and singing lessons and at send me to
Summer Camps so all credit to my career
is to my mom but you also talk about
your struggle with with your body
growing up you said that was something
that you had to I don't want to say
defend yourself but you wanted people to
know I feel good about myself in Hawaii
that was a struggle for you as well oh
yes it was a struggle and I also have to
say that you know when you grow up in
the church I was always covered you know
my mom would put me in these suits these
three-piece suits I look like Maxine
Waters and Steve Harvey's they look
crazy okay well Steve Harvey's very well
dressed but
[Laughter]
um I then began to grow into myself and
love my body because I started to see
that representation I saw you know
people like Queen Latifah and Retta and
Yvette Nicole Brown and Kimberly a bear
and divine Joy Randolph and I said you
know what if they're doing this on TV
maybe I can do it too so I'm excited I'm
excited to be that representation for
anybody else who may be watching and
saying okay Alberta she's sexy she's a
1920s Pro but she never goes she has
these romantic interests and she looks
good so it feels it's an honor to be on
the show I'm still thinking about Steve
Harvey
oh yeah so thank you those were sharp
okay Danielle Pinnock thank you very
much it's great and happy birthday
special places in two and You're Gonna
Want a season two for the finale of
ghost tonight at 8 30 7 30 Central right
here on CBS or on Paramount Plus